[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
construire de manière écologique
c'est une belle idée mais comment nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de ceux qui
ont franchi le pas nous avons eu un peu
de mal à trouver notre première maison
cette drôle d'habitation se cache dans
le coteau de montgivray dans l'indre la
maison bull
c'est le rêve de philippe delage
construite avec du fer de la terre et du
ciment elle se veut économique et
écologique
alors il est bien ce matin parce qu'elle
est orientée plein sud
donc on met en place un concept
américain le patch on pose de la terre
sur la maison sur la terre on va mettre
un isolant et par de solides on remettra
nateur le but c'est que la terre qui lie
entre l'isolant la maison elle va
s'assécher petit à petit va personnes
une son humilité
le soleil chauffe la maison par la chute
la chaleur va dans la terre qui est
derrière
pendant six mois elle accumule et les
six mois restants
eh bien c'est la chaleur de la terre qui
revient vers maisons les maisons bull
sont nés dans les années 60
conceptualisé par l'architecte
finlandais en petits lots vague qui en a
réalisé plusieurs dont le célèbre palais
bulles de pierre cardin aucun angle
seulement de la rondeur pour être en
symbiose avec notre planète
la population augmente les ressources
diminuent et un moment donné tout ça ça
se croisent et ça fait boum
donc il faut je crois aujourd'hui
recherché chacun de son côté je pense
qu'on peut rechercher des solutions
moi j'apporte ma solution ce sera le
petit habitat bioclimatique enterré mais
il ya d'autres personnes qui vont
chercher des solutions avec des maisons
en bois avec des maisons en paille
nous laissons philippe delage à son
univers de barbe à papa
direction la beauce et ses champs de blé
c'est un producteur de paille que nous
rencontrons didier thomas a commencé à
faire des petits bals au il y a 6 ans
pour les centres équestres
je produis 240 tonnes de paille par an
dont 5 % est consacré pour l'instant à
l'éco-construction avec approche paille
c'est à dire des maisons faites en
isolation pagnes et j'aimerais bien que
ça débuts sur mes temps de monter à 10
15 ou 20 % de la production qui partant
en écoconstruction ce serait sympa
il faut une certaine dimension aussi
bien hauteur largeur longueur une
pression de paille et aussi la
température qui est hyper importante
parce qu'il faut de la paille de très
bonne qualité
les ballots de paille de didier thomas
nous les retrouvons chez les a et son
mari ils ont acheté 560 pour 1000 euros
pour construire leur maison
il n'y a pas que la paille qui est local
et si on a du pin douglas qui a été
coupée en sologne qui a été du coup mis
en forme à la syrie un grain qui est à
20 km ici on a du panneau osb aussi qui
vient de sully-sur-loire à 20 kilomètres
d'ici on a du coup la paille de notre
agriculteur qui vient de 30 kilomètres
d'ici et ici là c'est du chanvre du coup
qui vient de vendôme à 100 km d'ici on a
lu des livres on s'est renseigné sur
internet
après on a participé à des chantiers
participatifs du coup on allait chez des
gens les aider à construire leur maison
et puis au fur et à mesure on a
rencontré des gens du réseau français de
la construction paille voilà qui eux
essaient de construire une filière mais
qui aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus
évoluée qui a six ans la paille
une filière qui commence à se structurer
grâce à des organismes comme accords
paille
la météo permet pas forcément d'avancé
que vous voulez a priori c'est la paille
est un isolant très performant et peu
onéreux pour les autoconstructeurs il
n'y a quasiment aucune contrainte
mais gare à la revente on a beau
construire sa propre maison et y
habitent et on prend ses propres risques
mais si on vend la maison dans les dix
ans qui sont la garantie décennale
nécessaire pour les professionnels on
est responsable d des dommages causés
éventuellement pendant les dix années
qui suivent il est temps vraiment que le
monde du bâtiment les constructeurs les
architectes les artisans l'ensemble
s'intéressent à ce matériau de
construction
parce qu' ils répondent vraiment à un
besoin contemporain eux
problématique environnementale sur
lesquels nos enfants en tout cas nous
pose des grosses questions
tout le monde n'a pas la patience et la
motivation de l'oea nous avons rendez
vous avec thomas manière le représentant
des maisons baby hommes aux abords de ce
village du berry s'achève la
construction d'une maison passive
bioclimatique
ici pas de terre ni de paille à rien que
des matériaux traditionnels et du bon
sens on a des maisons qui sont très
compacts ont il ya quelques années la
mode était aux maisons plutôt or en l ou
en u et nous simplement en ayant des
maisons qui sont un petit peu plus
compact c'est à dire plutôt carrée ou
rectangulaire on va déjà gagné de façon
significative en termes de performance
énergétique ça c'est un standard dans
nos maisons bioclimatiques une très
grande baie vitrée qui mesure trois
mètres et qui est orienté ici plein sud
pour avoir véritablement de la
luminosité et un certain confort à la
fois en été et en hiver également donc
là on l'aperçoit un peu au fond on a un
cellier dans lequel viendra s'intégrer
ce système de chauffage donc là c'est
une pompe à chaleur en l'occurrence coût
de ce pavillon de 72 mètres carrés cent
mille euros prêt à habiter un prix qui
augmentera avec l'arrivée de la
réglementation thermique 2020 en juillet
prochain
il faut apprendre à nos artisans comment
travailler surtout avec les nouveaux
matériaux qui vont arriver dans les
prochaines années d'avoir véritablement
un travail de formation effectué
construire écolo c'est une affaire de
volonté dans l'habitat collectif aussi
direction saint doulchard dans les
faubourgs de bourges
cet immeuble de 21 logements sociaux
construits il y as est en fait la fierté
de salim le gardien et le bonheur de ses
locataires
[Musique]
bonjour madame je vous avais bien s'il
ya quand même l'air qui renouveler tout
c'est pas comme dans un autre
appartement vous reconnaitre moi j'ai
déjà eu un appartement à vendre mais bon
c'était pas isolée du tout comme ici les
bruits tout ce qui s'en suit je peux
même vous dire ce que je paye pas de
souci si vous le voulez 11,95 tous les
mois une facture de chauffage dérisoire
et pour cause ce seul cette petite
chaudière approvisionne les 21 logements
elle permet de faire l'appoint voilà
elle se suffit à elle-même vous avez un
bâtiment qui est vraiment bien isolé
vous avez quand même quadruple e
isolation vous avez du triple vitrage
vous avez une vmc quand même double flux
et double fonction forcément vous ne
chauffez jamais dans le vide et quand
vous produisez de la chaleur elle reste
dans le logement et en plus elle est
homogène des performances que salim
transmettent au directeur général de
france loire le bailleur social à
l'origine du projet en termes de
logements sociaux on est vraiment au top
nude les gens aiment
les gens les gens ne peut pas trouver
mieux actuellement c'est du passif c'est
la gamme au dessus du bbc vous avez déjà
aujourd'hui qui ont fait l'économie
quasiment d'un an d'un mois de salaire
ce qui est énorme et forcément ben ça a
changé leur vie moi j'ai des gens qui
partaient pas en vacances notamment les
retraités ceux qui ont des petites
retraites qu'ils étaient obligés de
rester là où vous voyez qui partait de
trois jours moi j'en ai aujourd'hui qui
parle de trois semaines choses qu'il ne
faisait pas avant
avec les panneaux solaires ce bâtiment
passif qui a bénéficié des aides des
collectivités locales consomme environ
80 % de moins qu'une construction
traditionnelle
la construction de ce bâtiment ça a été
un véritable challenge dès le démarrage
puisque dans les années 2008 on ne
parlait pas véritablement de bâtiments
passifs et c'était une première
nationale à l'époque que de construire
un bâtiment sur trois niveaux en
ossature bois et en plus avec un label
passivhaus ça a été compliqué parce que
les entreprises ne savait pas construire
ce bâtiment
donc il a fallu préalablement à l'appel
d'offres pour recruter des entreprises
formées des entreprises les cales à des
techniques leur permettant de répondre à
la consultation et ensuite de pouvoir
construire le bâtiment
donc ça a duré un peu plus longtemps que
d'habitude mais à la fin on a livré un
bâtiment et on a livré également un
savoir-faire une construction exemplaire
qui a coûté 25 % de plus qu'un bâtiment
traditionnel
ce qui explique sans doute que
l'expérience n'est pas été renouvelé du
moins pas encore à ce niveau de
performance
notre dernière visite nous emmène à
tours ou six familles ont décidé de
fonder une copropriété écologique sur un
terrain commun les six maisons ont été
préfabriquées en usine puis assemblés
sur place
l'isolation des toitures est en laine de
bois la structure des murs en paille
avec une ossature bois et revêtement
naturel
il est composé de sable de paille et
d'argile et c'est de l'argile du jardin
donc c'est la terre d'ici donc vraiment
du local
si marie madeleine habite seul son
trois-pièces sa voisine lui si vite avec
son mari et ses deux enfants
la première chose c'est d'avoir des
grandes baies vitrées côté sud ce qui
permet d'avoir un maximum d'apport de
lumière et donc de soleil et donc de
calories d'énergie quand il fait beau
comme ça là on voit bien on acquis à
combien on à 21,5
alors qu'on à 12 degrés dehors quelque
chose comme ça ensuite la deuxième chose
c'est d'avoir une des murs très isolant
est étanche à l'air coût du mètre carré
tout compris 2600 euros soit environ 20
% moins cher qu'une construction
traditionnelle à tours on habitait un
appartement on était chauffée à
l'électricité
je pense qu'on a divisé par 5 ou 10
voire veut le voir dit snow consommation
pour le chauffage pour la partie
chauffage
clairement c'est énorme ans pose pas la
question là c'est juste
on doit utiliser à peu près 80 euros de
bois par an pour chauffer la maison
sachant qu'on aime bien peu notre
confort on n'est pas à 19 ans on est
plutôt à 21 21 degrés au quotidien
au delà des maisons c'est une autre
conception de la vie qui rassemble les
familles elles partagent le jardin mais
aussi un parking à vélo et en voiture et
une salle où tout le monde se réunit
pour un repas ou une discussion autour
d'un projet de voitures partagées ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est
éventuellement après de donner vos
coordonnées de permis de conduire oui
c'est ce que tu disais oui d'accord mais
le truc les lignes en jaune le numéro
des livres et de voilà qu'à par laquelle
préfecture et du coup ce qu'il faudrait
qu'on joue ensemble c'est si vous avez
des jours précédents
je pense que c'est ce qui nous rassemble
tous en fête ce côté
préservation des richesses
deux planètes c'est ce qui nous
rassemble quand même les maisons
écologiques passive et c'est déjà cette
problématique là donc c'est notre socle
commun on aimerait aller encore plus
loin là on est en train d'essayer de
voir si on peut mettre en place d'une
production de photovoltaïque ou autre on
a train d'essayer d'aller plus loin
visez un peu l'autonomie même si on met
ça paraît compliqué mais c'est un peu
l'objectif oui et c'est pas qu'une
histoire d'air du temps c'est que ça va
être indispensable à notre à nos yeux il
y a trois ans que les habitants de la
copropriété invente un quotidien qui
leur ressemble vivre ensemble et
protéger les ressources c'est forcément
trouver d'autres solutions
[Musique]